[UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYING]
REBECCA FRANKS: Hello, everyone.
My name is Rebecca
Franks, and today I'm
going to be speaking to
you about Android Things
and why I think it is the
IoT platform for everyone.
So what is Android Things?
Android Things is an extension
of the Android platform
for IoT and embedded devices.
We've come to know Android
on our phones for many years,
but Android has also
been available for us
on our watches, on our
TVs with Android TV,
and also in our cars
with Android Auto.
Now, with Android Things, you
can have Android on any device
that you can imagine.
So Android Things is ideal for
powerful, intelligent devices
that need to be secure.
Some examples of where Android
Things would really work well
is in the retail industry, for
things such as interactive ads
or vending machines powered by
Android, Also in the business
industry, with things such
as cameras, smart access
meters, anything of that sort.
In the logistics
industry, you could
think of using Android Things
in some form of application
of asset tracking or
predictive service.
But Android Things is also very
suitable for home automation.
So a smart doorbell or an
energy monitoring system
would also do well
with Android Things.
So a question that you're
probably wondering is,
how similar is Android
development to Android Things?
And the answer is it's
very, very similar.
So when you're developing
for Android Things,
you're using the Android SDK.
So all the APIs and all
the different things
you've learned as
an Android developer
are similar for you to
do with Android Things.
You're also using
Android Studio.
So you're just
building an Android app
and using it and putting it
on your Android Things device.
You can also use
the Play Services.
So something like the Nearby
API or the Vision API,
you can use on Android Things.
And because it's
just Android as well,
you can use the Firebase
SDKs and leverage
the real-time database or most
of the other Firebase options.
You can also use
the cloud platforms.
So things such as the
Google Cloud IoT Core,
or any of the Pub/Sub,
stuff like that, you
can use with Android Things.
And the best part is, because
it's just an Android app
that you're building, you can
use any other Android library
that you've been used to.
So if you like developing
your apps in Kotlin,
or you're a big
fan of RxJava, you
can do that with
Android Things as well.
So now we've seen how
similar Android Things
is to Android development.
But there's a couple
of differences
that you have to
keep in mind when
developing for Android Things.
So the first big
one is that there's
no Play Store that you're
shipping your apps onto.
So your app is the only one
that runs on the device.
And there's no such
thing as a Play Store
where users can go and
install other apps from.
There's also a subset of APIs
that are available for you.
So things such as
your notifications
aren't available anymore,
because displays are
optional with Android Things.
Also, when you're developing
for Android Things,
you're using custom hardware.
So this is probably
the biggest difference
when you're developing for
Android versus Android Things.
So the custom hardware
that you build
is what you ship
to your clients.
So we're used to
shipping our apps,
building on the Play Store,
and having people download it
from the App Store, but
this is people building
their own hardware,
shipping the hardware
and the software together.
So it's also useful.
And it's used as a
single-purpose device.
And what I mean by that is that
your app and your stuff that
runs on this device is the
only thing that will be there.
There's nothing else.
So the users aren't installing
anything else on the device.
And then, because
there's no Play Store,
you're deploying
OTAs to your clients,
and not app updates
like you're used to.
So this is the typical software
stack of a traditional Android
mobile device.
Kernels and libraries
are primarily
focused on enabling
hardware driver support.
Application frameworks
provide a rich set of APIs
for our apps to use.
And applications provide
user-facing use for general use
cases, such as our
launchers, our phones,
and our messaging apps.
Now, with Android Things,
we remove a couple
of these different APIs
and applications that
have been typically available
for you as an Android
developer.
So the default user-facing
apps have been removed.
So you no longer have
the launcher or the phone
or messaging capabilities
on Android Things.
Optional displays also mean that
some APIs have some modified
behavior.
So things such as your
notifications or your System UI
have been removed
with Android Things.
Now when you're developing
for Android Things,
you get the Android
Things Support Library
as part of your developments.
So some things, such
as the peripheral I/O
and Device Management, come
bundled with Android Things
SDK.
We'll go into a little bit
more detail around those later.
So Android Things uses a
system-on-module architecture,
or a SOM architecture.
So the system is designed around
a core computing module that
is located on a bigger breakout
board during prototyping
and development.
And then when you
move into production,
this smaller
system-on-module chip
is used and bolts on a
custom breakout board
that you would ship
to your clients.
This reduces costs
and simplifies
hardware development because
of the complex hardware design
that is encapsulated
within the SOM.
The Google-managed
Board Support Package
create a stable software layer
for developers to rely on.
So this means if your
hardware design should change,
you don't need to worry as
much because the Board Support
Package will support it.
So SOM-based designs make
production certification
testing a lot easier to do.
So all electronics
in the market must
undergo some kind
of certification
before you ship them
to your clients.
And this process can
be very, very costly.
And when you are using the
SOM architecture design,
it simplifies this cost.
And Google handles all
the complexity for you.
So when you are developing
with Android Things,
there's a couple of things
that are managed by Google
and things that
are managed by you.
Google manages the Android
framework, the hardware
libraries, and the Linux kernel.
So you don't need
to worry about that.
And then you as a
developer will need
to manage the apps and
user drivers that you
will ship onto your devices.
You no longer need to worry
about sending security updates
or maintaining an OS.
Android Things
maintains that for you.
So the Android Things
Console is what
you would use as a
developer to ship
OTA updates to your devices.
So you manage your Android IoT
product on this Android Things
Console.
You can download and
install the latest version
of Android Things system images
on this Android Things Console.
And you can also
build factory images
that contain the
OEM applications,
along with the system images.
On this console itself, you
can also push OTA updates
to your different clients.
And if you head over
to partner.android.
com/things/console, you can
head and see this Console.
Taking a quick look
at the Console,
though, this is what
you would typically see
if you're developing your app.
I've created this
candy dispenser.
And on this, I set that I want
to include the Google Play
services with it.
But this is what
you would typically
see when you're managing
your own product.
If you head to the Factory
Images tab on the Android
Things Console, you
can see exactly where
you would need to upload
your applications that you're
shipping.
So it's what we call a bundle.
It's just the file that
contains your APKs that you
want to ship, as well as
possibly a boot animation,
if you want to change that.
You can then choose the
version of Android Things
that you want to be building
your firmware version for.
And then you can download
this factory image
and flash this on the
devices that you're using.
If you've already got devices
out and in production,
you can then ship OTA updates
by doing the same process,
selecting the bundle
and the factory image,
and then doing push updates.
Cool.
So we've got a little
bit of background
on how Android Things
works and what it is.
So I'm going to take
a quick look at how we
can develop for Android Things.
So to get started
with Android Things,
you would need to purchase
or obtain a Developer Kit.
So there are two that
I particularly like,
the NXP i.MX7D or
the Raspberry Pi 3.
And these, what you
would typically do
is with a Raspberry Pi, you
would download the factory
image and flash
it on the SD card,
like you would normally do
with any other operating
system for Raspberry Pi.
You would then
start up the device.
And you would have Android
Things running on it.
From this point on, you can
connect to it over Wi-Fi
or via the USB cable.
I particularly like the NXP a
lot more than the Raspberry Pi,
because it's a lot
easier to debug.
So when you're
developing, you can just
develop over the USB cable.
And you don't need
to worry about Wi-Fi.
So because we're
developing custom apps,
we can use custom
hardware with our devices.
And in order to access these
different hardware peripherals
that we might include
on our devices,
there are different
options for you to do.
So I like to think of it
as two different ways, one
being the difficult way
and one being the easy way.
And the peripheral
I/O extension is
what I like to think of as a
bit more of a difficult way.
But basically what
this gives you
is access to all the
different protocols
that you might be used to if
you have done any kind of IoT
development before.
So things such as your
GPIO or your PWM protocol,
you can get access to those
using the peripheral I/O
manager.
But this does sound
a little bit tricky.
So if this is not
your thing, you
can head to the peripheral
Java library on GitHub,
and this gives you
access to a whole bunch
of pre-built
drivers that you can
use within your Android
Things application.
So things such as a GPS or
a button or a server motor
are all available for you if you
head to that link down below.
So I like to think of it
as if you don't really
know what you're doing
with Android Things,
you can do the GitHub library,
versus if you are more
into getting
lower-level access, you
can use the standard protocols.
So we're going to try
and quickly build an app.
Basically, what we
have on screen here
is a breadboard with
a button and an LED.
So this seems really simple.
I mean, why do we need
Android Things involved?
But we're just going to have
Android Things control the LED
when the button is pressed.
So what we're going to
do is we have two pins
that we're using in this case.
And this is what I like to
refer to as the pinout diagrams.
So this might be a
little bit confusing.
But if you have
these devices, you'll
see there's about 40 or
so pins on a Raspberry Pi
or on the other kits.
And because they look the
same doesn't necessarily mean
they do the same thing.
So what you want
to do now is we're
going to be using BCM6 for the
button and BCM21 for the LED.
So what we're going to
do is in Android Studio,
we would head to Creating
a New Application.
So in Android Studio 3.0,
we create a new project.
And we would select the
Android Things as an option
that we want to build for.
We can then choose to
have an empty activity
that we are using.
And then automatically
the app adds
the compile-only dependency into
your app-level build.gradle.
Now, at the moment, the latest
version is 0.5.1 -devpreview,
but this is constantly
being updated.
So make sure to check
out the latest version.
So automatically in your
Android manifest file,
we've added the
users library tag,
which indicates that you need to
use the Android Things library,
that the device requires
this library to be installed.
Then on that activity
that we created,
we have added an intent
filter automatically.
So this means that when
the device reboots,
it will automatically
boot into this activity
that we've created.
You would need to add
this stuff yourself
if you haven't gone through
the Create New Android Things
Project from scratch.
You would need to do
these all yourself.
Now, in our example,
we had a button
that we were using in order
to get pressed events.
So what I'm going to
do is use the button
from the GitHub support
library that we saw earlier.
So I'm just using
it within Gradle,
putting it in my
build.gradle file.
And now I get
access to a button.
So I would create a new
button by saying = new Button,
and I'd give it the pin that
we were talking about earlier--
in this case, BCM6 pin.
Now you must just remember that
this button is not the same
as the android.widget.button.
It is a different one from
the Android Things Support
Libraries.
Now what you can do is
set an on-click listener
on the button.
And this will get fired whenever
we receive a physical button
press.
And all we are going
to do in this case
is set the value of our LED
GPI open to true or false.
Now, this might be a
little bit confusing first.
But we'll get into
the LED GPI open next.
The next thing we need
to do is make sure
that we close the button
access that we have.
This just frees up any resources
that we were using before.
So to get access to
the LED that we have,
we would just get access to the
peripheral manager service API.
So what this is is it's provided
by the Android Support Library.
And you can just use it
by importing and using
that compile dependency.
So we would just then say,
service.openGPIO with the pin
number that we used previously.
And then we would set
the direction of the pin
to [? art initially ?] low.
And then we can access that
pin and set it to true or false
if we need to.
Now that's where we
would do in the button.
We would set it to true
when the button is pressed.
And we get the
button event false
when the user lifts
up their finger.
We would also need to then
just close up this pin as well.
So in our onDestroy method,
we would then typically
go LED GPI.close.
And there we have a blinking
LED powered by Android Things.
So now that we've seen how to
build a simple Android Things
project, there's a couple of
examples that I want to go
through that you can have
a look at if you head
to hackster.io/Google.
So the first example
is by Dave Smith,
and this is what we
call the Edison Candle.
Now, you might think it's a bit
silly to have a candle powered
by Android Things.
But this example is
for you to understand
how to go from a prototype all
the way into production and all
the different things you would
need in order to get there.
So be sure to check out
that project on Hackster.
The next project that
I want to highlight
is what they call
the Piano Hero.
This one is actually on
display if you go head up
to the Android Things stand.
And this one is basically
just using a keyboard
powered by Android Things.
And you can sort of play
something like Guitar Hero
but for piano.
And this was built by
the team at Novoda.
And then one other one
that I'd like to talk about
is my own one, and this is
what I call an electricity
monitoring app.
Now, where I'm from
in South Africa,
we suffer quite regularly
from power outages.
And I had this problem where
I didn't know when I had power
at home versus when I didn't.
So I built this app using
Android Things and the Firebase
SDKs.
And all the app does is
runs on my Pi at home
with no other
peripherals connected.
And when I don't
have power at home,
I get a notification on my
phone to say the power is off
or the power has come back on.
It also keeps track
of how long I've
had power for at my house,
which is really useful.
So how I did that
using Firebase,
a quick little code dive.
Basically, with Firebase,
you get a really nice SDK
called the info.connected.
And this tells you if you're
connected to the internet
or not.
So technically, my
electricity monitoring
is actually just
a network monitor,
but my network's a lot more
reliable than my power,
so for me, it serves me fine.
So what we would do here is
we would just get access to
if I'm online or
not, and then we
add a value event
listener on this.
And then for this
part, we would then
check on the data snapshot,
am I online or not?
And if I am, set the value
on the server to true
and add what we call the
onDisconnect Listener.
So this is where
it becomes super
powerful, because the
onDisconnect Listener says,
when this client
disconnects from the server,
on the server, set a certain
value to true or false.
And then on my server, I'm using
the Firebase Cloud Functions
to determine if I should
send a notification or not.
I'm monitoring this node.
And if anything changes,
a push notification
gets sent down to the device.
Another cool project
that I actually
built myself is what we
call an AI Candy Dispenser.
So this one has been
built by Alvaro Viebrantz.
And you can find this
one on Hackster as well.
But this one, what's really
cool about it is it's
using the TensorFlow API
offline on the device.
So how it works is when
you press the button,
it asks you-- you
play a game with it.
So it asks you, please
show me a photo of a cat
or a lion or
something like that.
And you have to quickly go
search for one on the internet.
Or maybe you have some of
those objects lying around.
And then show this
image to the device.
And it uses TensorFlow to
try and classify the image
that it has on the device.
And then it says yes or no.
It's a cat.
It's a lion.
You've got it right.
And then it dispenses candy.
And this is all powered
using Android Things
and the TensorFlow libraries.
So I encourage you to add
your project to hackster.io.
And you can head to
hackster.io/google.
So if you've built anything
with Android Things,
please be sure to
add it there, as it
will be really valuable
for everyone else to see.
So why Android Things?
Well, it's the power of
Android in your own hands
on these devices.
Google manages the complexity
of automatic and secure updates.
And it's a lot easier
for you as a developer
to manage these things.
So if you're still curious about
learning more, at 1 o'clock
there's an instructor-led
training by Renato
on Hands-On Learning
with Android Things.
And you can actually create
your own IoT device there.
I'll be available in the office
hours upstairs on Floor 3
if you have any questions.
And on your way out,
there will be IoT cards
that you can get
your own IoT device
at this conference itself.
So thank you very much.
Cool.
[UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYING]